If you're struggling now more than ever
before with reaching the right people
consistently, meaning you historically
may have reached these pocket audiences
and you've been in there for maybe weeks
or sometimes upwards of months at a time
and then all of a sudden it changes. Now
with the world of Andromeda factored in
that can actually happen far more
frequently. Niche messaging is being
distributed at a larger rate than
majority hooks from what we've seen in
this postandromeda world. Just to be
extremely clear with you, the effects of
that tiny hooks are reaching pockets of
people that you may not be intending to
reach and they're creating a lot of
chaos inside of businesses that don't
know what to do when it comes to
messaging best practices as it directly
relates to this post Andromeda Facebook
algo update. We're going to go through
all the best practices in this video.
Don't worry, I got you. If you're on
your path to million-dollar months, this
is a perfect channel for you. That's all
we talk about around here. If you are
looking to tack on that first million a
month or the next million a month. All
our content's made for rich people
trying to get a hell of a lot richer,
you're in the right place. We don't make
any income claims, though. The US Bureau
of Labor Statistics claims that.1% of
businesses ever achieve $10 million and
an annual run rate, let alone the even
smaller quantity of people that ever
achieve milliondoll months. So, just to
be clear, there are no income claims or
earnings expectations. We have no idea
who the [__] you are. We just pass down
these lessons to you from clients who
have been there, done that for what's
working right now today. So without
further ado, ladies and gentlemen, let's
dive in. And of course, if you're a
subscriber, welcome back. Absolute
pleasure to have you. Another banger for
you here today. So what we've seen at
this most recent mastermind that we just
concluded here for our Q4 talk in good
old the end of 2025 in the post
Andromeda world, the businesses that
were crushing it are doing a lot more
creative testing than they ever have
before. and they're finding that the
smallest things are controlling and
influencing more than ever before who
they're going to reach and how long
they're probable to reach them for. I'll
give you a perfect example of this. One
of the inner circle members, Mason, gets
up on stage and he mentioned a very
simple thing in almost a joking way
where he said, "You know, one time we
were talking about something that didn't
relate at all to writing or articles. We
just mentioned the use of AI and the
power of copywriting with being able to
replicate long books such as authors
like JK Rowling. And because he
mentioned that author's name, the famous
author who wrote all the Harry Potter
books, he got a bunch of authors through
his funnel. And that wasn't his intended
audience. There was nothing else in that
entire thing besides those few words,
the name of a famous author and a word
like author that immediately started to
reach a fuckload of authors. And so
here's the number one thing that you
have to remember in this post Andromeda
world, and that's the fact that
everything's more sensitive now than
it's ever been before. Sensitive in the
sense that literally one word or
sometimes a handful of words can wildly
influence who you're probable to reach.
And of course, those pocket audiences,
some of them are large and some of them
are small. I compared it at this most
recent mastermind that we just did to
like little pockets of oil. I said, you
know, if you bought like a piece of
land, like let's say it's, you know,
20-ish thousand acres and you wanted to
drill for oil and you know, you're
naturally like 30 40 years ago when that
was in its heyday. You're going to build
these little wells up here and you're
going to dig deep into the ground until
you hit a little pocket. And then
naturally, the amount of oil that's
within this specific pocket dictates how
productive this specific well is. And as
you can imagine, there's wells that they
build that, you know, they don't hit any
pocket. maybe because they didn't drill
deep enough or because those pockets
were rather shallow. And so even if you
hit the right pocket and you use the
right terms to influence who you're
probable to be getting in front of,
sometimes even when you're speaking to
the perfect person, there's only so many
of that perfect person that's actually
probable to be in that little audience
in that given moment. And so what we're
finding is Andromeda is doing such a
powerful really good job at getting very
niche almost micro hooks in front of
those smaller pockets. And so what we're
seeing is there's more of these smaller
pockets being exploited than ever
before. But that also reduces the amount
of time that you can be exploiting that
specific pocket audience for. You
understand where I'm going with this?
What you have to do is you have to
recognize that when you get the right
people coming through and you did the
right things with dialing in your
messaging to attract that type of person
and all of a sudden you see the wrong
types of people coming through, you
likely ran out of people in that pocket
and you likely need to go back and do
creative testing again. That's really
what Andromeda is all about is taking so
many more creatives that have been
loaded into this platform than ever
before, whittling it all down to a few
thousand, and then handing it off to the
2023 update that Meta did called Metal
Lattis. It's the simple retrieval and
ranking algo steps. But now it's better
than it's ever been historically. And as
a result of that, those little pockets
are being exploited more than ever
before. Here's the downside, though, and
if you've run ads, you know exactly what
I'm talking about right now. You need to
load up about we find the pocket to be
25 to 30 unique creatives in an ad set.
And so for let's use the example you're
doing video ads. We'd film 25 to 30
totally unique creatives. No shared
bodies and CTAs. Everything's unique
through and through. And all those
different reasons all those total unique
creatives. One to three are going to get
all the reach. [laughter] So as a result
of only one to three total creatives
getting all that reach and distribution,
the other, let's say you launch with 25,
right? the other 24 to maybe 22, they're
going to get barely any money spent.
Sometimes, without exaggeration,
pennies. Now, that doesn't negate the
fact that we still have to launch with
25 to 30 total creatives to get the
impact and the positive benefits of what
Andromeda can truly provide. However,
yeah, it's kind of frustrating to look
at it and say, well, I mean, none of
these other ads got reach. But this is
also kind of the cool part. All we
really have to do is in that example,
duplicate out our ad set, remove and/or
just turn off the creatives, the one to
three that got all the reach, and then
let those other ones start to test
against each other. And that's kind of
the cool part. In the process of doing
so, you reach newer pockets and you may
have that potential to finally hit that
bigger pocket. And if you have, let's
say, a really finite demographic of
people that you believe you can convert,
what you have to be really good at is
articulating yourself from multiple
perspectives about that thing. So let's
use the example that this specific
demographic is your current pocket
audience. And it's small in this
context. Okay? You believe that there's
a finite amount of people that in a
given moment under specific
circumstances and conditions are ready
and probable to buy what you have.
You're not necessarily a mass market
brand. You've got a high ticket product
or service after all. and it's specific
for somebody's problems relative to your
problem and solution scenario. What you
have to learn to be really good at is
articulating that thing from so many
different perspectives. And we break
this down into really just three simple
things. Okay. Number one, the problems
that that individual has. Number two,
the circumstances that that individual
finds themsself in. Okay, circumstances
are powerful. And in addition to that,
we can also articulate ourselves from an
outcomes perspective. Now, these three
specifically, when you think in the
context of those and you just try to
list as many reasons that you can think
of, what you end up doing is you're able
to talk to that same pocket audience so
many times over because you have
mastered the success of being able to
rotate the problem, circumstances, and
outcomes that that specific individual
that you're trying to talk to wants. And
you also remember rule one, which is the
sensitivity part of it. Don't say
anything that wouldn't bring in the
right types of people. And all it comes
down to is the simplest of words
nowadays in this post Andromeda update.
Once you do an exercise like this,
there's a lot of power in it because
what you can do is what we teach our
inner circle members and master internet
marketing students, which is to leverage
specific credit-based LLMs to go into
it. This would be something not like
Chat GBT or Claude or Gemini. There's
credit based LLMs that you can use and
the incentive is far greater. A
credit-based LLM will read all the
transcripts that you upload into it word
for word. It fully consumes a lot more
training material and doesn't operate
with the guard rails of efficiency that
a monthly flat rate subscription LLM AI
tool would use comparatively. You want a
credit-based LLM. Okay? Now, we have
many of those that we teach and talk
about inside of our inner circle
program, our master internet marketing
program. You're watching here for free
on YouTube after all. So, I'm going to
give you a lot, but I'm going to hold
back some stuff so you eventually give
me some money. [laughter]
Anyway, long story short, links in the
description for that if you're
interested. Back to this. When you do
this specific exercise and you do it in
a way where you're thorough, you load up
specific training material documents
into that LLM, it can kick you out
consistent ad ideas for that specific
person, leveraging real world agentic.
This is very important. Let me actually
backtrack a bit. all these preferred
credit based LLMs. I also want you to
understand it should have an agent mode
where it can go out there. All agent
mode really is is just kind of like
somebody using a computer on your
behalf. That way you can go out and
actually do research to find context for
these specific reasons and people. That
way you also factor in highly believable
reasons on top of all this. That's a
different lesson though. Long story
short, get yourself into the position
where you have the clarity of this and
just unlock a lot because you're going
to need a lot of creative angles to talk
to that same exact pocket audience from.
That's what you do if you have a small
audience. Now, if you have a large
audience, it's more in the context of
the oil field analogy. Consider
everything that I just said like you've
got this pocket, you've got this pocket,
you've got these tinier little pockets
like this and this as well. The moral of
the story is from your perspective when
you have more audiences that you can
convert. So if you've got a lot of
audiences rather than just one type of
audience, meaning simply put, there's
more than just one type of person that
you can realistically sell to. That's
exactly what you do. You do the same
exercise but for all those different
people many times over. And so simply
put, and this is this is a really long
lesson made into the simplest words.
There's a lot more to this that I could
sit here and articulate, but again, like
we're going to keep that reserved for
the people who actually give us some
money. You're still going to get a ton
of value from watching this. I promise
you that all these pocket audiences,
let's say you have audience type number
one and two and three and four and etc.
For the rest of all these, you do the
same exact thing. You list off all the
specific problems, circumstances, and
outcomes of those specific types of
people because that's the moral of the
story with Andromeda. I have an entire
video on my channel dedicated to
Andromeda and all of what it entails so
you can understand it. If this is a new
word to you and you're not familiar with
this ALGO update, make sure you go check
out that video because it'll give you a
foundational understanding of it and
what it requires of you. But just in a
simple nutshell, it requires a fuckload
more creative than you've ever loaded
into it prior. And it requires
diversification in messaging. So you
don't get the opportunity to have the
efficiency that you've historically had
by doing something like just filming
opening hooks and then posting the same
body in CTA. There's a creative
solutions specialist that works over at
Meta. He's on Twitter. He's got a couple
low thousand followers, but he tweets
some great stuff. And one thing that he
recently tweeted was this alpha test
they're running. and they're considering
rolling out a column in the ads
dashboard there that shows you creative
that's too similar to one another either
visually or in messaging because
technically what Andromeda requires is
diversification in messaging themes and
visuals in Meta's words. Now, we found
from our testing that it really just
requires messaging but it doesn't hurt
if you're not getting the results and
outcomes you want to also factor in the
tests of themes and visuals. Either way,
moral of the story, once you get to the
point where you realize you're going to
need, as I said, about 25 to 30 unique
creatives every time that you go to
launch an ad set, you don't have to do
that every time over. Once those one to
three ads distribute and take all the
reach and all the spend, and they
inevitably fatigue and your pocket runs
out, you're just going to relaunch the
adset and just pull out one to three and
you can load up a new one to three. And
then the other 22 to 25 that you loaded
up, depending on how many you launched
with, will put you in a position where
you're now testing all over again. cuz
the smaller ones that didn't get reached
that had pennies spent before, they
deserve to have spend go to them again.
So, it gets efficient after the first
time that you do it, unless you find
whatever you're running not bringing in
the right people. And then you got to go
back to the drawing board and consider
what are reasons that are probable to
actually attract the specific people
that you want to have come through that
funnel. Messaging is literally
everything. It does all the targeting
nowadays. Meta is a broad targeting
platform now. Meaning, yes, your
targeting is there, but it's counted as
suggestive nowadays. Okay? And so what
that means is is messaging controls
everything. I hope this video helps you.
Go check out all my other videos on my
channel. They're far helpful for people
that are rich trying to get a lot
richer. Check out the links down in the
description. Subscribe to the channel if
you haven't done so yet. Listen, at the
very least, give me a thumbs up and a
comment down below on what you thought.
Appreciate all your feedback. Go out
there and get richer. toxin.